Cassian Andor lives before the Battle of
Yavin in the year bby5 but he doesn't
know that because the pivotal Star Wars
event the system of time is based on is
still years away time is a fleeting
concept one that becomes even more
amorphous when considering how it might
function across an entire galaxy
according to NASA our Milky Way galaxy
is thought to contain somewhere between
100 to 400 billion stars and measures
100 000 light years in length this means
that if you were so inclined to travel
from one edge of our galaxy to another
it would take hundred thousand years of
traveling at the speed of light to reach
the other side needless to say the
vastness of space can be something of a
daunting Prospect regarding the
conventions of time and or is Disney's
latest ROM through its Flagship Star
Wars Universe chronically and how Cassie
and Andor becomes the Die Hard Rebel
leader featured in Star Wars Rogue one
time wise Andor is a prequel television
series that takes place before the
original Star Wars trilogy but after the
Star Wars prequel trilogy placed in its
story smack dab in the midst of a
fermenting Rebellion more specifically
the very first moments of Andor see
Cassian walking into a city one and the
show mentions that this is taking place
during bby5 obviously that denotes a
year however what exactly does bby5 mean
in the real world our calendar
categorizes yours as either the secular
BCE and CE referring to the Common Era
or BC or 80 which is a system heavily
influenced by Christianity BC stands for
before Christ while A.D is Latin for
anno domini which translates to in the
year of the Lord so what does BBY mean
in Star Wars could it mean before baby
Yoda for example unfortunately no grogu
is not part of the Star Wars dating
system however BBY does reference an
incredibly historic moment in the Star
Wars Universe the Battle of Yavin where
the non-hardcore Star Wars fans Yavin 4
is the moon that hosts the secretive
base of the Rebel Alliance in the first
Star Wars movie The Battle of Yavin
refers to the Skirmish that results in
the destruction of the first death star
black ass spoils an attack position
[Music]
this means that Andor takes place five
years before this momentous event this
is a victory that Cassie and Andor is
partially responsible for in Rogue one
he AIDS in the theft of the original
Death Star Plans by stealing these plans
Cassian and the rest of his team provide
the rebel alliance with the means to
destroy the Death Star which otherwise
would have become yet another symbol of
Imperial oppression from that point on
years in the Star Wars Universe are
denoted as before the Battle of Yavin
AKA BBY or after the battle of Yavin AKA
ABY Cassian Andor and the rest of the
characters featured throughout and or of
course do not know they exist in the air
bby5 given that the Battle of Yavin is
yet to occur according to books like
2015 Star Wars absolutely everything you
need to know galactic authorities at one
point considered year zero to be the end
of the Old Republic era featured in for
example the acclaimed Star Wars video
game Knights of the Old Republic an
interesting note is that the way time
passes on what was once a galactic
Capital Coruscant is akin to how time
passes on Earth meaning that a standard
year in the Star Wars Universe similarly
consists of 300 65 days of 24 hours the
Old Republic air meanwhile ends at
around BBY 1000 so if Cassian indeed
uses the system that considers the end
of the Old Republic as year zero during
the events of Andor he likely
understands himself to exist somewhere
around the year 995. sometime after the
battle of Yavin the BBY ABY system is
introduced to the Galaxy eventually
granting its inhabitants the same time
keeping device frequently shown viewers
[Music]